to make stackable chips they use a ratio
of one-third water to two-thirds potato
flakes with a little cornstarch mixed in
a conveyor delivers the mix to an auger
which disperses it using four tons of
pressure they roll the mix into one long
potato sheet a rotary cutter punches out
oval shapes a device pulls away the
scrap dough leaving flat uncooked chips
the scrap dough is recycled into the
chip making process the cut chips head
into a fryer as they travel through the
fryer rolling moulds give the chips a
concave shape this shape makes them easy
to stack the chips spend 11 seconds
frying and hot oil
this makes them crispy they travel under
blowers to get rid of excess oil the
chips get a coat of seasoning then do a
back flip off one conveyor onto another
falling in neat piles
a worker inspects the rows of chips then
it's on to another conveyor that shakes
them up to loosen the stacks they travel
over scales to be portioned out for
packaging automated spoons feed the
chips into the opened ends of the tubes
guides tap the top of the tubes to nudge
the chips into position grippers lower
the stack tubes to a station where
spinning heads force on metal bottoms
now they're ready for shipping it takes
about 20 minutes to make a tube of
stackable chips but it takes less time
to polish them off
you